أجنبي
[موسيقى]
لست
كذلك إذا كان من
المفترض أنه على حق وأنا
أخشى الفشل لأنني لا أفشل
مرات عديدة ، لذلك ربما
يكون على حق ربما
لم أعد معتادًا على الفشل
ولكن  الحقيقة هي أنه
متخصص لأنه ثماني سنوات بدون
قطعة فضية وهذا أمر عادل رغم
[موسيقى]
لكنني لا ألومه على الإطلاق لقد سئلت
عن شغفي وأنت تعرف لأن
معظمكم في صحافتي
كنت أتحدث عن نفسي
ثم كان السؤال إلى مدير تشيلسي
كما قلت إنه يتصرف مثل مهرج
ربما يريد الصحفيون أن يقولوا
ذلك ولكن لم يكن لديهم الشجاعة لقول
ذلك ، لذلك أخبرنا مورينيو أنك
تتصرف مثل  مهرج حتى لا ألوم
مدير تشيلسي على الإطلاق وأنا أفهم
رد فعله كنت أتحدث عن نفسي
قائلاً إنني لست بحاجة إلى التصرف كمهرج
لإظهار الشغف
[موسيقى]
بينما نعم [
موسيقى]
[موسيقى]
تركيا
UNICEF
No Sisters
الأجنبية
[موسيقى]